ben asks gary what have your children
taught you about life and business
first of all that was a great video big
ups i think the instagram videos have
huge potential as well the creativity is
coming through more than the youtube
videos were just persons face so that's
a lot of fun you know what's funny i
took this question as well because i
think my answer is going to be super
unpopular i think i think a lot of
people are going to be you know
everybody's looking for the romantic
answer right like you know the truth is
i love my kids
insanely but i love my wife and i love
my parents
so insanely that
you know i love them more but like
drock's always scared when i go
politically and correct no drock i mean
it's the truth i i promise to be very
honest on this like do i love my kids
more to my parents it's a really
interesting debate for me it's much
closer than the normal
politically correct or answer that i
hear from others so it's not like they
taught me how to love you know people
say that all the time i was [ __ ]
loving everything before um
i guess um you know i guess at the end
of the day
the things that really really uh
you know what this is the true answer
the the thing that my kids have taught
me about life and i guess i believe this
very much in business and so many of you
that have been jamming with me for a
long time know
they've taught me from the other side
how powerful dna really is
watching my kids do the same exact
things i do like misha when she performs
in our living room she's spending more
time trying to pay attention if we're
paying attention than on her actual
performance that's what i do when i give
talks i'm like looking in the crowd to
make sure they're not on their phone
like you know xander's looks of like
like i got you like it's just crazy so
like they've taught me how powerful dna
is it's you know
and um and maybe they taught me to uh
you know
maybe they've taught me a more extreme
level of respect for lizzie um she's
just an incredible mother and just
watching how she's executing in her role
with them is is uh
has taught me a lot about her
um but for me you know they haven't
taught me jack crap about business
um and
other than the reason i bet on people is
based on my intuition around their dna
and then i watched their dna come full
throughout i'm just a big dna guy
hey